[Music]  my name is rachel campos duffy i've been  with fox for seven years  well the first thing that struck me was  how family friendly it was so it's no  surprise to fox viewers that i have a  very big family life i have lots of kids  mom  and my producers the bookers  everyone was so willing to work with my  crazy life and i thought that was  something i never expected and then  finally i had my ninth child i recall  just thinking to myself all right  i had to tell them i'm having nine kids  like this has got to be like the  threshold of where fox can handle my you  know life complications it's gonna be  chaotic guaranteed the executive was  great we're so happy for you like that's  a mommy's dream it's something i'm an  odd i still say thank you i'm so  grateful to be here